i just want to commend you guys for
making such a powerful and great film
and at the same time i wish i never saw
this movie um it's one of those kind of
things and i'm sure you guys feel the
same
um it's you know uh
that's a weird way to start an interview
but it's such a powerful film um uh and
but so i like throwing a curveball at
the beginning um before we get into the
film and this is for the actors uh for
you guys if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
super easy i think for me it would be
the movie
right now this is
no no it's a totally valid that that's
i've heard that from many people i ask
this question to a lot of actors yeah i
think that's probably the answer
okay
i'll move on and just say uh you've got
an abundance of riches to choose from
with these guys look at their repertoire
everything's amazing
yeah they're they're all yeah yeah i i
agree um uh abby i'm curious um i know
it's a little generic but how have you
been describing the film to people um
how do you i mean i know it's like the
uh how have you been describing the film
it's a one-man sincere-hearted rebellion
against a broken system what was can you
sort of talk a little bit about um how
you actually first connected to the
material what it was that said i have to
make this film
sure
well first off i was flabbergasted that
i hadn't read or heard about brian's
story uh when it happened because
usually you you feel like this this
story would be um
with such a sensational
tone to it we would have heard about it
it would have popped in in the national
news um but when i read erin gill's
article which is my first encounter with
the story i had never heard about it and
i actually saw it when i was driving my
car so i pulled over to the right side
of the road and read all 30 some pages
of it and i wept my heart was broken
that the story hadn't been told um in it
i saw a reflection of
guys that i knew growing up that were
close with my dad and my dad's a vet as
well and i saw his own struggles his
quiet rage his his desperation reflected
in brian's story
and
there was an intimacy and a a beauty in
brian uh in his his uh quiet refrain of
of
longing for dignity
that uh
i felt that that i understood on a deep
level and then i partnered with kwame to
to make sure that we told brian's story
honestly there's so many different
themes that are happening in our country
that needed to be talked about honestly
and and uh
not sure uh if he wasn't able to log on
or something's going on but
um if if kwame were here he he would say
that um that heartbeat
that heartbeat of brian's story was one
that resonated strongly with him and
that he had to tell as well
um for the cast i i know you guys have
all read scripts many times scripts like
this do not come along too often and i'm
just curious what was your initial
reaction um after reading this and your
emotional connection to the material
i was really moved moved by the material
really really moved um
especially it came at a time where i
hadn't been reading a lot
and and um i had
spent a lot of time with with family and
so it was a quiet time for
for separation from work but this
scripture was something that my my agent
was just like you really really do need
to read this and you wouldn't guess this
is based on a true story this is
actually crazy and in reading this and
discovering brian and his um connection
to his his daughter there's one
perspective as a human being and i'm
kind of like wow this is a incredible
story this is incredibly moving and the
other perspective of of an actor and
that is also a great opportunity to show
versatility as well and to jump into a
role that i i feel like was written to
be quite powerful and and dynamics
whereas the other roles we have in this
as an ensemble so it all just you know
balance that for me from just reading
that script
honestly it was after having a
conversation with abby and then going uh
reading reading the script and then
reading the article that the script was
based off of and and
being in shock
similar to abby that no one that i
hadn't that i hadn't heard about this
story and i think
i as i text abby there was so much anger
and frustration that you feel uh
for brian for this situation for the
entirety of this situation for
everybody's lives connected to it to his
daughter to his to his ex-wife to his
family um so i think
it was i i just had such a profound
reaction um and as as john was saying
during the time period being you know
with family and and having this kind of
quiet reflection and being able to be a
part of something that feels bigger than
you and has a message and is important
and and can change
um a conversation or a narrative or an
understanding is something that doesn't
come often
yeah um
after reading it um
[Music]
it's it's so well told every
all these people have such a vested
interest and um that they're real people
that it's a real story abby's passion
and drive obviously just like magnetizes
to it but um i also at that moment in in
my life and the moment in the pandemic
was sort of having a conversation with
myself about like disability the able
versus the disabled and how we're
treated in society even people with like
immuno compromises etc um
and this in a very strange way still
kind of addresses that addresses like
how people can be just discarded um if
they don't fit within a certain like
neurotypical
um
you know framework uh and so i just
wanted to sort of get behind that and
yeah yeah i thought it was a really
beautiful way of of doing that and
having that conversation about what we
do as a society
um i have spent i've learned over the
last number of years how frustrating it
is to deal with the va uh before this
film and i'm just curious what did you
guys sort of take away or what did you
learn or what do you want to shine a
light on about the
what the people have to deal with at the
va because it just it's so frustrating
it's um it makes you very angry i didn't
ever think about
the the va particularly when i first
read it it didn't build like the
frustration about the va it was more
about this man like
this and this this baby this daughter
who
who because of the the circumstance of
of the lack of support coming back can't
be the best he can be to uphold you know
a family unit that can make sure this
baby's taken care of you know
you just imagine it from different
perspectives
as well and and the script itself allows
you to do that but you're seeing how
other people's lives are
kind of tied into this you know tragic
tragic event and this
this the failure the failing of a system
but at the same time just the crumbling
of a man just as by himself like just
his individual story so for me it was
i was i was
most certainly broken by
by how he saw himself at his his
existence his state of existence like
that to me
because you know
i'm the type that we will get will feel
can feel incredibly sorry for someone
but when you're then getting the details
like abby had a lot of information and
then you're in the environment you're
now seeing the bank you're realizing now
this is this was a real man's
life i think it was more about for me
anyway you know about his individual
path rather than
the the qualms of the va because it
seems to be very clear that people know
about the confusion that they cause
i would imagine that um
that i am actually curious when you're
making something that's this heavy in
the material and so serious what is it
actually like in between takes on set um
are you
for the cast are you guys staying in
some sort of emotional space to help you
with the next take or do you find that
you're like leaving that and just trying
to decompress i'm just curious i love
talking to actors about how they work on
set
to me it felt uh
taking the lead from abby you know and
and taking the that approach and how um
i really
i admire how direct and
and and clear she can be with her giving
of direction and that kind of sets the
tone for everybody's professionalism on
onsets
um and i think there's just a common
understanding of
respecting
the story and and showing up
your best to your best ability and and
being present with with your partner and
being available to your to to this story
and i think that was set from the top
down
steve i can you know from my bird's eye
view of all the different actors
processes everyone works differently and
needs something different for what their
role demands and we had a lot of really
demanding parts
uh john i mean wow the nuance the the
beauty of of everything that you
captured for brian it's a very demanding
role
for nikki it's it's something where
you're constantly in a state of
heightened tension like all of your
senses have to be alert and awake and
it's a different demand of someone who
has the safety of their home um until
that safety net is broken with olivia
and
the demands of those things my job is to
facilitate the needs of an actor to be
able to do their best work right so you
know sometimes you do that perfectly
sometimes you don't and you find you
find the the rhythms of that within each
actor um
and it's it's a beautiful thing when
salinas and and nikki are able to play
off of each other within that tension
and build a relationship and
uh
when when
john and and mike
are in separate spaces but building
intimacy because they're on the phone
together and and able to directly
communicate and pierce through all of
the infrastructure that is around their
characters it's it's a really lovely
thing to see the the the
the
art of it come come to life
uh welcome welcome to the uh welcome to
the party
hi kwame
welcome to me
i'll let you just got the time wrong
i'd love i'd love to come on and blame
technology or blame something
please i'm just going to blame me
sorry we're happy to see you at any hour
kwame god bless you sorry guys
um thank you for joining us uh be i i
have i will have a question for you but
uh abby i am i love talking about the
editing process just because that's
ultimately where it all comes together
um and i'm curious if you could talk a
little bit about what it was like in the
editing room uh crafting this story um
and uh
if you could just talk about the
challenges or lack of challenges
you know so often in in our film i was
really privileged that it was really
clear which takes were were right um it
felt like
in in nikki's work in john's work in
libya's work they were building towards
something in a lot of their takes and
yeah there's nuance within those but so
often it was okay let's go one more
let's go one more and oh i need one more
or
and
for me it's like great you want one more
you've got another idea that can make it
richer and stronger and and more
powerful and more truthful i love that
and and so often those are the takes
that make it uh more nuanced more alive
more truthful and that's what we're
after right so on the
when we're editing and actually i live
right here um
the the
the choice becomes really clear because
those are the most truthful ones and
then you just shape it around what is
most truthful so i think my first cut
you just put everything that's great in
there
and then it's a matter of saying okay
well we kind of repeated that b here
which one's stronger
um and that's it that's your job as a
director just leave the leave the good
bits and the strongest and most truthful
bits in there i love learning about like
the behind the scenes of making movies
shows uh and learning like cool things
that you might not know so for all of
you guys what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of the film or something you'd
like to share with people that was
really special to you
that for the majority of the phone calls
were all present
um even though i was in the house and
john was in the bank john was actually
in the house and i was at the bank
so that was fun
and for folks who don't know usually for
phone calls there's the director on the
other end of the call or the script
supervisor and you lose
you lose quite a bit of authenticity in
the
in the communication between the actors
but if you've got the actual character
on the other end of the line you're able
to capture that truth that vibrancy and
really the conflict that's inherent to
the calls
yeah and i i mean i was going to say
that it felt like um
it felt theatrical in nature and that we
were present and in the
circumstances almost all the time while
we were in the space while we were for
the i can only speak for the bank people
um that's how it felt
to me
um
yeah
yeah that that that's a very particular
thing because a lot of times it's about
like
your coverage and getting bits and
pieces and it was like no matter what we
were doing we were still
in
the world and there and there was no
sort of i think that's why that earlier
question that you asked about whether we
stayed in it or what we did we kind of i
don't know if we stayed 100 in the
circumstances but it wasn't like and cut
and now we're like listening to the
radio and talking about sunday and what
we like did we very much were honoring
the energy of the space and also we were
shooting during the height of i think
the first delta wave
so there was that sort of increased
we had it within the actual story but
this increased hyper vigilance as well
about like our safety and just the world
that we're living in that i think also
kind of feeds the story in a way you
know i think it takes a lot to shoot
during those moments um
you know and so hats off to the cast and
crew and all the directors
first
i mean salinas isn't here but i'm sure
if she she would she would speak to to
you because you two played off of each
other so beautifully
and it was incredibly demanding for both
of you to live under that vigilance that
um
that that hyper tension of everybody
gonna come that's everyone that was
working even just the crew i mean
everyone was like we have to stay
well we have to keep this thing going
you know um and you and you could feel
it um
yeah and then especially with what
john and salinas were giving you know
what you
i don't know how you even made it
through with all the energy you were
expanding because i feel like that would
completely deplete anyone's immune
system
he was like full gasket blown but yeah
yeah
uh well kwame we haven't spoken to you
yet and i'm just curious how did you how
did you and abby actually hook up to
write this together and work on this
together
we have a mutual manager max and uh and
i was in los angeles and he said you
kind of got to meet this filmmaker abby
if you don't you'll you'll regret it and
uh and she's working on this at the
moment
and and then sent me
uh the article i i read the article i i
watched abby's film
and then i turned up at dinner and
begged
he likes to rewrite history this guy
you know i
the the truth of the match is once one
read the story
and realize that this wasn't
as large as any of the other big events
that we have seen in racial justice
history
um
um i i was in
but from the moment that i also read and
realized that this was this was a
quintessentially 21st century heist
he didn't take no money
he held hostages but what he did say was
listen to my story he called a local
media station and said listen to me
and and that i i found really really
fascinating and uh and wanted to
to be part of the baton pass on
because i think he entered into that
space and said
you know listen to me
he called
the the stations and said listen to me
and even though that happened the story
was still not as amplified as it should
be and i think that that abby myself and
this brilliant collection of artists
have kind of just taken the mic taken
the baton and said we will continue to
sing your song
that's why
i'm very thankful that you guys um uh
made this film um my last question for
you guys because i got a wrap uh what
does it mean for all of you to be part
of the sundance film festival and
getting to show this uh at such a such a
great fest
it gives us the platform oh please john
no no no it definitely is a it's a great
it's a great platform you know i was at
sundance a good few years ago and
i didn't really understand what it was
at the time i was just kind of like you
know just getting into the industry and
stuff so after i realized oh
you know it is a platform for a lot of
creatives to to connect and for a lot of
people to see a film that they wouldn't
usually usually see you know we all know
what where our industries are big
studios aren't making movies like this
as much
um and to see you know especially a
first-time director like abby being
given a chance to make something dynamic
and then
now
the the right eyes will will potentially
be on this movie i think it's a great a
great opportunity um obviously i was i
was hoping to be back to a face-to-face
sundance um to just to get the feel of
the vibe and meet the filmmakers but
obviously we know what was for the best
of our health and stuff but it it's good
to know we can do it at least do it this
way and still communicate and connect
and i hope that
people at sundance and the audiences are
going to see the movie get it and and
and have the opportunity to see it
it's my first sundance
and uh you know and i'm a bit like yo
and it's virtual which i think again is
magnificently third decade of the 21st
century you go
why be physical yeah
let's just switch john so i i know that
but most importantly i'm really i'm
really proud um that this film has made
it to sundance really proud of abby's
work that that led us here and i'm
really magnificently proud of of the
actors and the artists that put
everything in to make this because this
you know it nearly didn't make it
and it's it is a testament to
everybody's tenacity and brilliance that
here we are having this conversation so
i'm just proud that we've made i think i
have to stop there because you have
other interviews to do i'm just going to
sincerely say and uh i watched a lot of
movies uh they're not all this good um
and i just want to commend all of you
guys for uh for such a great job and for
telling brian's story
thank you thank you
you